for a store near you.
>> Jesse: BIG HOLES KEEP
"FIRE AND FURY".
THE ALLEGED INSIDE ACCOUNT OF
25th AMENDMENT PROVIDING FOR
REMOVAL OF THE PRESIDENT BY HIS
CABINET WAS, QUOTE, A CONCEPT
THAT IS ALIVE EVERY DAY IN THE
WHITE HOUSE, END QUOTE.
BUT THEN HE HAD THIS TO SAY
THIS MORNING.
>> DID YOU SPEAK WITH ANY
MEMBERS OF THE PRESIDENT'S
CABINET FOR THIS BOOK?
>> I DID NOT.
>> YOU DIDN'T.
>> DID YOU SPEAK WITH THE VICE
PRESIDENT?
>> I DID NOT.
>> A LITTLE BIT OF A GUEST
AROUND AND JOIN US AGAIN AND IN
OUR NATION'S CAPITAL IS DAVID
GOODFRIEND WHO WAS DEPUTY
SECRETARY TO PRESIDENT BILL
CLINTON, CHIEF OF STAFF.
NOW, THIS GUY NEVER EVEN
INTERVIEWED THE VP, NEVER
INTERVIEWED THE CABINET
OFFICIALS.
I DON'T THINK HE EVER
INTERVIEWED ANY OF THE FIRST
FAMILY THAT HE TALKED TO
IVANKA, OR ERIC OR DON JUNIOR.
A LOT OF THIS STUFF DOESN'T
RING TRUE, DAVID.
HOW MUCH OF THIS DO YOU THINK
IS JUST PURE FICTION?
>> THIS IS WHY I DON'T DIVE
INTO STORIES OF PALACE INTRIGUE.
THEY ARE OFTEN WAY OVERBLOWN.
HE SAYS HE SPOKE INITIALLY GAVE
THE IMPRESSION THAT HE HAD
SPOKEN TO EVERYONE.
THAT HE HAD THIS UNFETTERED
ACCESS AND HE COULD WALK AROUND.
MAYBE HE DID FOR A LITTLE BIT.
YOU'VE BEEN IN THE WEST WING.
I'VE BEEN IN THE WEST WING.
IT ISN'T THAT EASY TO GO IN AND
OUT OF ROOMS AND NOW HE CAN'T
ANSWER POINTED QUESTIONS.
THESE QUESTIONS WERE NEVER
ASKED BEFORE THE BOOK CAME OUT.
THEY JUST TOOK IT AS "FIRE AND
FURY", A TRUMP ADMINISTRATION
IN ITS DEMISE GOING DOWN IN
ANOTHER BOOK THAT IS SALACIOUS
LIKE A BAD SOAP OPERA EXCEPT
THIS ONE WON'T BE BACK IN
I DON'T UNDERSTAND HOW THIS
MAKES SENSE.
THE CENTRAL PREMISE OF THE BOOK
IS THAT TRUMP DIDN'T WANT TO
WIN THE ELECTION.
SO IF HE DIDN'T WANT TO WIN THE
ELECTION, WHY WAS HE COLLUDING
WITH THE RUSSIANS TO WIN THE
ELECTION?
I DON'T GET IT.
>> YEAH.
THERE IS A LOT OF KIND OF WEIRD
QUESTIONS THAT POP UP AROUND
THIS BOOK.
I WOULD BE THE FIRST TO SAY
THAT AS WELL.
IT REMIND ME WHEN I WORKED IN
THE CLINTON WHITE HOUSE YOU HAD
PEOPLE WHO WOULD LEAVE THE
WHITE HOUSE AND WRITE THE EXPO
SAY BOOK WHICH I THOUGHT WAS
BETRAYING THE PRIVILEGE OF
HAVING WORKED IN THE WHITE
HOUSE.
I THINK HERE, TOO, WE SHOULD
JUST ASSUME.
FLAT OUT WRONG.
JUST WRITE IT OFF 50% OF IT.
WHAT'S BEEN SAID IN THIS BOOK
IS LOOK AT THE PRESIDENT'S OWN
REACTION.
IF SOMEBODY SAID SOMETHING
ABOUT ME THAT'S A LIE I WOULD
BLOW IT OFF.
I DON'T REACT.
THIS PRESIDENT BECAME THE FIRST
PRESIDENT IN U.S. HISTORY TO
PRONOUNCE I'M SANE, REALLY, I
AM.
THAT MAKES ME THINK HE IS
PROTESTING A LITTLE TOO MUCH.
HE SHOULD BE QUIET.
>> Jesse: WHY THE PRESIDENT HAS
TO SAY SOMETHING LIKE THAT.
SAYING THE PRESIDENT OF THE
UNITED STATES IS CRAZY AND THEN
HE IS ASKED TO RESPOND TO THAT,
THE HEADLINE THEN BECOMES THE
PRESIDENT DEFENDS HIS SANITY.
THINK ABOUT IT.
>> THAT'S WHAT THE MEDIA DOES.
>> FOX NEWS PEOPLE SAID BARACK
OBAMA ISN'T REALLY A CITIZEN OF
NOW PRESIDENT OBAMA DIDN'T JUMP
OUT AND SAY I'M REALLY A
CITIZEN, REALLY, I AM, HERE I
AM.
NO.
>> I DON'T KNOW WHO ON FOX NEWS
SAID THAT, DAVID.
I CAN'T NAME ONE PERSON ON FOX
BIRTH CERTIFICATE.
NOW THE BOOK IS BECOMING A BEST
SELLER PRECISELY BECAUSE TRUMP
IS TALKING ABOUT IT.
IT MAYBE KNOCKED HIS BOOK DOWN
A FEW RUNGS OFF "THE NEW YORK
TIMES" BEST SELLER LIST.
IT IS SO FUNNY TO BE CALLED
INSANE BY THE LEFT WHO IS
SCREAMING AT THE SKY, WHO IS
WEARING HATS WITH GENITALIA.
BERNIE SANDERS THINKS GLOBAL
IF ANYBODY IS INSANE IT'S
PEOPLE ON THE OTHER SIDE.
>> THIS COMPENDIUM OF WHAT'S
FALSE AND WHAT'S TRUE.
HE DELAYED THE FAKE NEWS AWARD
UNTIL NEXT WEEK.
I DON'T CARE ABOUT THAT.
I CARE ABOUT POLICY.
THAT'S WHAT I CARE ABOUT THAT.
THEY PUT ALL THIS STUFF AT HIM
AND YOU ATTACK THE MAN, HIS
REPRESENTATIVE COWEN ATTACKS AN
11-YEAR-OLD, BARRON, HIS SON ON
TWITTER.
WHAT DO YOU EXPECT A FATHER TO
DO?
WHEN PRESIDENT TRUMP BECAME
PRESIDENT HE DIDN'T GIVE UP HIS
RIGHT TO SAY WHAT'S ON HIS MIND.
NO PRESIDENT IS OR DOES.
I LIKE A GUY WHO IS GOING TO
FIGHT.
I'M SICK OF THE LEFT THROWING
PUNCHES AND THE REPUBLICANS --
>> I'LL SEND YOU GUYS A BOX OF
TISSUES AND WIPE YOUR TEARS.
>> LET ME TELL YOU, DAVID, YOU
ARE A GOOD MAN BUT I'M LIKE
TRUMP.
>> Jesse: I WANT TO PLAY SOME
UNDERMINE PRESIDENT TRUMP THAT
IS JUST UNFOLDING TONIGHT.
HE IS AT THE COLLEGE FOOT BALL
NATIONAL CHAMPIONSHIP THIS
EVENING.
HE TOOK THE FIELD FOR THE
ANTHEM AND SANG ALONG.
BUT NOW PEOPLE ON THE LEFT ARE
CLAIMING HE DOESN'T KNOW THE
WORDS TO THE NATIONAL ANTHEM.
ALL RIGHT.
TWITTER AND THEN WE HAVE AN
EDITED SHOT TO SHOW YOU FROM
WHEN HE SANG THE WHOLE THING
WORD FOR WORD.
TAKE A LOOK.
>> WHAT SO PROUDLY WE HAIL AT
THE TWILIGHT'S LAST GLEAMING ♪
♪ O SAY DOES THAT STAR-SPANGLED
BANNER YET WAVE ♪
>> Jesse: I DON'T KNOW IF YOU
COULD SEE THE VIDEO THERE, GOOD
FRIEND.
THE GUY IS SINGING ALONG WITH
THE NATIONAL ANTHEM AND NOW THE
TOP TREND ON TWITTER IS SAYING
TRUMP DOESN'T KNOW THE WORDS TO
THE NATIONAL ANTHEM.
I MEAN, GIVE IT A REST.
>>
I LOOKED AT THE VIDEO.
YOU TAKE A LOOK FOR YOURSELF
AND FROM MY VIEWPOINT SOMETIMES
HE IS SINGING ALONG AND
SOMETIMES HE IS NOT.
SOMETIMES HIS LIPS ARE MOVING
AND SOMETIMES THEY AREN'T.
I DON'T KNOW IF THAT MEANS HE
DOESN'T KNOW THE WORDS.
YOU ARE JUMPING TO CONCLUSION.
>> Jesse: DO YOU THINK THE
PRESIDENT OF THE UNITED STATES
>> NO, I THINK HE DOESN'T LIKE
I DON'T LIKE TO SING, EITHER.
IT'S NOT BECAUSE I DON'T KNOW
THE WORDS.
>> THE PROBLEM IS THE LEFT IS
-- HANG ON, DAVID.
THE LEFT ASSIGNS A VALUE IF HE
DOESN'T KNOW.
IT'S WHAT THEY DID TO REAGAN.
THEY ASSIGN THESE VALUES TO
OUT AND SAID THE PRESIDENT WAS
BEING BOOED SO I LISTENED TO IT.
I WATCHED IT LIVE AND I REWOUND
AND THE FIRST THING I SAID WAS
THE LEFT WILL COME OUT AND SAY
HE DOESN'T KNOW THE WORDS WHEN
THEY KNOW NOTHING.
LIKE A PSYCHIATRIST WHO KNOWS
HE IS CRAZY BUT HAS ACTUALLY
NEVER TALKED TO HIM.
GETTING BOOED WHEN GEORGIA IS
I HAVE TO RUN.